hi I'm Anthony Randazzo with the recent
TV I'm joined today by Peter Wallison he
is the Arthur F burns fellow at the
American Enterprise Institute and he was
a commissioner on the Financial Crisis
Inquiry Commission which was set up by
Congress to look into the causes of the
financial crisis Peter thanks so much
for joining us really good to be here
Anthony thanks the commission that you
were on found that the crisis was caused
by a mixture of deregulation of Wall
Street greed predatory lending and many
other things why do you say that this is
wrong there's absolutely no evidence for
anything that the Commission the
majority of the Commission put in their
report
the financial crisis was the result of
government housing policy by 2008 there
were 28 million subprime or other very
weak mortgages those are known as vault
a mortgages there were 28 million of
those in our financial system of that 28
million 20 million twenty point four
million were on the books of government
agencies like Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac
and FHA and other government agencies
and banks that were holding them as a
result of the requirements of the
Community Reinvestment Act Stanford
political economist Francis Fukuyama
recently in an interview said that's
your descent to the commission's report
was transparently designed to exonerate
free markets did the crisis have nothing
to do with free markets my point was
without the government's housing policy
there would never have been a financial
crisis that's not exactly the same thing
as saying that government housing policy
caused the financial crisis it's stating
in another way and that is if we hadn't
had the government's housing policy that
is our but for the government's housing
policy there wouldn't have been a
financial crisis many economists that
have claimed that it was the structure
of Wall Street growing too big for
itself and becoming too interconnected
that even if you presume the government
was necessary for it to happen that we
still had to come in and bail out Wall
Street do you dispute this I will
dispute the idea that we had to bail out
Wall Street and for this reason that is
the government bailed out Wall Street on
the theory that all of these firms were
interconnected what it means according
to the government is that if one of
these large companies fails it drags
down others but when we look at Lehman
Brothers we can see that nothing that
Lehman Brothers did by failing had any
effect any significant effect on all of
these other firms yes there was chaos
investors ran that was caused by a
common shock common shock refers to a
case in which a very widespread asset of
some kind suddenly plunges in value and
the reason in this case mortgage-backed
securities backed by these low quality
or subprime mortgages do you see any
viable path forward to address Fannie
Mae and Freddie Mac after the 2012
election yes in fact the 2012 election
could make it possible for us to address
Fannie Mae Freddie Mac and the FHA I
might add that's that's one of the
factors the Federal Housing
Administration is important here to
every Republican presidential candidate
has said that the cause of the financial
crisis was Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac
and US government housing policy now
once you establish the right narrative
then the answers fall out by themselves
are you not concerned at all that there
are people in the Republican Party
significantly involved in preventing the
reforms to Fannie and Freddie that were
proposed in 2004 and 2005 that one of
the candidates for the Republican
nomination Newt Gingrich worked for
Freddie Mac in fact he was at AEI at
this point I was attacking Fannie Mae
and Freddie Mac at AEI in the 2000s 2004
to 2007 saying that they were a real
risk to the country and meanwhile two
doors down for me Newt Gingrich was
helping them persuade people that they
weren't so bad so I am concerned about
this history and I'm concerned about
these Republicans if these people say
that they are conservatives and many of
them argue that they are conservatives
they are not conservatives
if they are willing to back Fannie and
Freddie would you say that today's weak
economy is a direct result of the
financial crisis or there may be other
underlying aspects of why the US economy
has not bounced back strongly from the
last recession as that normally does
after it yeah I actually believe that it
is the reaction to the financial crisis
principally the dodd-frank Act that has
caused today's economy to be as weak as
it is without that if we had just let
the housing market decline let let
everything go down to the level where
people are willing to come in and start
buying that is where the the bottom is
found then we would have been in
recovery right now but the government's
actions in trying to prevent that from
happening its government's actions in
impeding the development of new
financing sources for housing have
caused the problem we are in today well
thank you so much I've been joined by
Peter Wallison from the American
Enterprise Institute for recent TV I'm
Anthony Randazzo